نتابع في اخبارنا حيث قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو انه رغم الثمن
الباهظ الذي تتكبده اسرائيل خلال الحرب
الدائره في غزه فانها ستواصل القتال حتى
النهايه وجدد نتنياهو في مستهل الجلسه
الاسبوعيه للحكومه قوله ان اسرائيل لن
توقف الحرب قبل تحقيق
اهدافها اندفعوا ثمنا باهظا جدا في الحرب
لكن لا مفر امامنا الا ان نواصل القتال
قواه نا قضت حتى الان على الاف المخربين
نواصل بكل قوتنا حتى النهايه والنصر
لنستكمل تحقيق كل اهدافنا بالقضاء على
حماس واعاده مختطفين وضمان ان تشكل غزه اي
تهديد لدوله
اسرائيل وقبل قليل افاد مراسل الجزيره بان
مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي سيجتمع غدا لمناقشه
منحى الصفقه المعروضه لوقف اطلاق النار
وتبادل الاسرى وفي كلمه متلفزه وجهها الى
الاسرائيليين قال الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق
هرتسوغ انه لا مافر من هذه الحرب للقضاء
على حماس وطالب السياسيين الاسرائيليين
بالتوقف عن الخلافات والجدل في هذه الحرب
الصعبه على حد وصفه معنا حول كل ذلك من
تلبيب مراسلنا الياس كرام
الياس كيف تبدو كل هذه المعطيات في ظل هذه
التصريحات من قبل السياسيين المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين التي تقترب
وتبتعد
سلمى واضح بان الخطاب الاهم هو لرئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو لان الرئيس
الاسرائيلي هو يحمل يعني هو ب منصب فخري
لكن واضح بان كلمه بنيامين نتنياهو هي
الاهم لانها كانت موجهه اولا للمجتمع
الاسرائيلي بعد ما تكبد الجيش الاسرائيلي
15 قتيلا في اقل من 24 ساعه وكان لابد
لبنيامين نتنياهو ان يتحدث الى المجتمع
الاسرائيلي الى الشعب الاسرائيلي ويقول
لهم بان هذه الحرب يدفع الجيش الاسرائيلي
ثمنا باهظا لها لكنها سوف تتواصل وسوف
تتعمق وهنا الاهم في حديث بنيامين نتنياهو
لان هذا الحديث يبدو انه كان يرد فيه على
منحى المبادره المصريه بالرفض الواضح يعني
هو الان يقول بان اسرائيل ماضيه في هذه
العمليه العسكريه وسوف تعمقها ولن توقف ها
الا بعد تحقيق اهدافها بالقضاء على حركه
حماس ولا تشكل قطاع غزه بعد ذلك اي تهديد
لامن اسرائيل وبالتالي فهم من هذا الخطاب
بانه يعني رفض من جانب اسرائيل لمنحى
الصفقه المعروضه من جانب مصر والتي تتركز
في ثلاثه مراحل تشمل بطبيعه الحال وقف
اطلاق النار اسرائيل ترفض وقف اطلاق النار
في اي اتفاق لتبادل الاس وترفض في المقابل
بحسب ما نفهم ايضا اي انسحاب عسكري من
داخل قطاع غزه اما بالنسبه لخطاب الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اسحاك هيرتسوغ فهو جاء خطابا
موحدا وكان هدفه ايضا الحديث ومخاطبات
المجتمع الاسرائيلي بعد ما تكبده الجيش
الاسرائيلي من من خسائر فادحه جدا في
الارواح وفي العتاد في الايام الاخيره
وتحديدا في الساعات ال 24 الماضيه اهم ما
قاله هو وجه رسالته الى السياسيين في
اسرائيل وقال تريثوا تريثوا لا تتج
تتعجلوا في حمله ال الحملات السياسيه ونحن
لا نريد ان نعود الى يوم السادس من اكتوبر
الذي كان المجتمع الاسرائيلي يعيش حاله من
الشقاق والخلاف السياسي وان العدو ينظر
الينا كما قال هرتسوغ والان الوحده
الوطنيه مهمه جدا من اجل الانتصار عسكريا
كانت هذه اهم ما جاء في في كلمه هرتس على
اعتبار ان هنالك كان واضحا بان هنالك
محاولات للخلاف والشقاق في داخل المجلس
الوزاري المصغر للشؤون السياسيه
ويه في اسرائيل تمجي اللوم للمستوى
العسكري تحديدا من جانب لافت الياس بانها
مناشده على في العلم من قبل الرئيس
الاسرائيلي بضروره توحيد المواقف وعدم
الذهاب الى هذا النوع من الخلافات بين
قاده مجلس حرب في اصعب وقت يمر تمر به
اسرائيل حسب ما يقول في ذات الوقت يعني
يعني هناك ايضا استحقاقات هي مهمه على
منتظره امام هذا مجلس الحرب مثلا الصفقه
صفقه المعروضه لوقف اطلاق النار وتبادل
الاسرى غدا بالاضافه الى ايضا المعطى
الكبير عن الاعداد الكبيره من القتلى
يوميا من الجنود
الاسرائيليين هو كان غاضبا جدا الرئيس
الاسرائيلي في في خطابه كان غاضبا جدا ولم
يخفي هذا الغضب في في حديثه وتوجيهه لهذا
اللوم الى السياسيين في اسرائيل الذي
بداوا في حملات سياسيه ضد الحكومه وليس
فقط ضد الحكومه ومجلس الحرب انما ايضا ضد
قاده الجيش الاسرائيلي وعلى راسهم رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي الرئيس هيرتسوغ
كان يوجه خطابه تحديدا الى الجناح المتطرف
في هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه تحديدا بنفير
و سموتريتش الذين وجهوا اللوم ووجهوا
كثيرا من من غضبهم على رئيس اركان الجيش
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي الرئيس هيرتسوغ قال
بان الوحده الوطنيه هي مهمه جدا في هذه
المرحله التاريخيه
والعصيبة شقاق والخلاف السياسي في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي ليس له مكانا الان لانه سوف
يكون له تاثير سلبي كما يقول على سير
المعارك وعلى ربما معنويات الجنود
الاسرائيليين في ارض ال المعركه واضح بان
هنالك خلافات ليس في مجلس ال مجلس الحرب
حول ربما منحى الصفقه لان ربما ال الثلاثه
الذين يديرون مجلس الحرب وهم رئيس الوزراء
ووزير الدفاع وا الوزير بيني جانس ربما هم
متفقون على انه يجب على اسرائيل الا توقف
هذه الحرب ولا وقفه لاطلاق النار في اطار
اي صفقه لتبادل الاسرء هم بطبيعه الحال
معنيون بصفقه يطلق بموجبها صراحه اكبر عدد
من الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين لكن هم
يشددون في كل المباحثات على امرين هامين
بالنسبه لاسرائيل اولا ان اسرائيل ستعود
للحرب بعد اي صفقه او ايه مرحله لتبادل
الاسرى وان الجيش الاسرائيلي لن ينسحب باي
حال من الاحوال الى خارج قطاع غزه تبقى
الخلافات الاخرى الموجوده في الجناح
المتطرف للحكومه الاسرائيليه المتمثل
بيتمر بنفير في كل ما يتعلق بمساله
المساعدات الانسانيه والطبيه التي تدخل
الى قطاع غزه مساله ادخال الوقود الى داخل
قطاع غزه هنالك خلافات في هذا ال المنحى
بطبيعه الحال بين الوزراء وهنالك يعني
وجهات نظر مختلفه من وزير الى اخر لكن
المنحى هو انه لا وقف لاطلاق النار ولا
انسحاب من قطاع غزه بموجب اي اتفاق لتبادل
الاسرى هذا الموقف الرسمي الاسرائيلي
المعلن حتى الان شكرا جزيلا لك الياس كرام
مراسلنا من تل ابيب